[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
notre invité se fait rare dans les
médias c'est une chance de l'avoir avec
nous aujourd'hui elle se fait rare parce
qu'elle passe beaucoup de temps en
tournée et ces tournées à elles sont
internationales son succès a depuis
longtemps et même depuis le début de sa
carrière largement dépassé nos frontièr
elle est disque d'or dans 6 pays diffusé
dans des dizaines d'autres chanteuses
auteur compositrices tous ces albums se
sont vendus à des centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires partout dans le monde ces
grands succès vous les connaissez
forcément il y a eu
[Musique]
celui-là
et puis il y a eu
[Musique]
celui-là cette voix ce son ces
instruments cet engagement dans ces
textes tout est atypique dans sa musique
même le fait qu'elle chante
exclusivement en anglais alors qu'elle
est née en France et qu'elle a toujours
parlé français on pourrait même s'y
tromper et la prendre pour une artiste
américaine mais pourquoi d'ailleurs
pourquoi ce choix de chanter en anglais
quand on a la subtilité et les nuances
de la langue française dans son cœur et
dans sa tête posons-lui la question
bienvenue dans un monde un regard
bienvenue à vous Imani merci d'avoir
acceptter notre invitation ici au Sénat
au dome Tournon pourquoi ce choix de
l'anglais dans vos chansons est-ce que
c'est parce que c'est une langue plus
musicale que le français c'est
exactement pour ça c'est vrai ouais
aussi parce que je pense que ma culture
musicale elle est
anglosaxon mes parents ils écoutaient
pas de musique en particulier enfin si
ma mère beaucoup de jodassin alors c'est
peut-être ah je sais pas mais
eu et puis et puis j'ai vécu aux
États-Unis 8 ans à partir de l'âge de 19
ans h et que c'est là aussi que ma ma
mon désir de faire de la musique qui
s'est vraiment euh enfin développer
enfin où j'ai pris la décision en tout
cas de de vraiment devenir chanteuse
donc j'ai appris j'ai pris des cours de
chant et comment on écrit une chanson
enfin j'ai j'ai vraiment appris sur le
tas sur le tar mais quand vous dites que
l'anglais est plus musical c'est c'est-à
dire c'est en terme de sonorité c'est la
volupté des mots c'est c'est quoi c'est
les deux en fait c'est la volupté des
mots c'est en terme de sonorité puis
c'est aussi c'est une langue on va dire
le français c'est une langue qui
supporte très mal le le premier degré
c'està dire que en anglais on peut
chanter dire qu'on est dans sa cuisine
et qu'on coupe des tomates ça sonne
c'est pas très grave et les gens sont
pas très choqués si ça sonne c'est plus
important le le si vous voulez le Grou
il est plus important presque que le
sens quand vous avez les deux c'est
encore mieux vous êtes Bob Dylan bien
sûr mais alors que que le français il
supporte moins
bien la médiocrité et donc vous chantez
sur votre dans votre cuisine vous couper
des tomates bon bah ça devient un truc
parodique c'est drôle mais c'est pas
c'est pas la chanson c'est plus
difficile voilà j'ai trouvé un titre
chanté en français dans votre album ex
le mot pardon plus exigeant ouais le
français mais c'est vrai le le il y a un
titre he chanté en français dans votre
album de reprise vousouello vous
reprenez les voleurs d'eau d'Henry
Salvador c'était la première fois que
vous chantiez en français c'est pour ce
titre là c'est une première alors c'est
la première premier titre enregistré oui
sinon j'ai toujours chanté une chanson
de Pauline CROSE qui s'appelait TBO en
live avec des violencelles d'ailleurs
ouais et et ce titre en fait c'est
vraiment un album de chansons je défends
pas des artistes je défends des chansons
donc je défends soit le sujet qui est
mis sur la table avec le la chanson soit
ça ça correspondait à une période de ma
vie que j'avais envie de de revivre
visiter et les voleurs d'eau c'est
vraiment ça c'est c'est comment on a pu
passer à côté d'un chef-dœuvre à chanson
française à ce point parce que la
plupart des des même journalistes musiil
la connaissaiit pas et c'est vraiment un
aspect de H saladur qu'on connaît pas et
c'est une chanson magnifique sur bah
l'écologie mais aussi le colonialisme
sur la solidarité entre les hommes et
les femmes comment est-ce qu'on peut y
arriver tous ensemble donc je trouvais
que c'é une chanson importante voouello
ça veut dire quoi quoi c'est une
référence vaudou c'est c'est c'est quoi
exactement vodouello littéralement ça
veut dire le violencel vaudou euh parce
que quand j'ai fait ce projet c'est h
violenelles et une voix et c'est tout et
je voulais que les violenelles sonnent
comme un projet pop donc comme presque
comme un basse batterie mais sans
trucage donc aller au plus loin de ce
que la violenceelle est capable d'offrir
et en fait on s'aperçoit que pour cet
instrument qui est très très ancien euh
et très organique très acoustique en
fait on va très loin ça sonne comme une
guitare électrique ça sonne comme des
cœurs parfois et ça sonne vraiment comme
si des fois il y avait des animaux
coincés à l'intérieur donc quand j'ai
voulu monter le spectacle parce que
c'était d'abord un spectacle dans ma
tête et ensuite c'est devenu un album ok
l'idée c'était de pouvoir expliquer aux
gens avec quelques mots où est-ce qu'ils
allaient atterrir et donc il fallait
rentrer dans le mystique et VO Chello ça
sonne aussi comme voodo child de Jimmy
Hendrix donc voilà à partir de ce
momentl à partir du titre j'ai j'ai
construit le spectacle vos modèles à
vous au départ c'est plutôt Tracy
Chapman Nina Simon h c'est ça oui ça
fait partie de c'est des artistes qui
m'ont inspiré qui m'ont touché qui m'ont
qui m'ont donné envie de faire faire et
continuer parce que je les ai pas connu
aux mêmes époques euh ce métier et c'est
des voix atypiques et je m'y retrouvais
un peu ouais ouais euh s'il fallait
donner un un un nom au style de votre
musique parce que vous savez bon en
France on aime bien aussi mettre les
artistes dans des cases savoir si c'est
pop rock renb pour vous on narrive pas à
savoir et et tant mieux j'imagine c'est
peut-être ce que que vous cherchez aussi
le la seule expression que j'ai trouvé
qui pourrait s'adapter à votre style
c'est peut-être musique du monde est-ce
que ça vous irait ça ou est-ce que vous
n'avez surtout pas envie d'être mise
dans une case bah je crois que personne
n'a envie d'être mise dans une case oui
bien sûr mais j'ai jamais essayé de
chercher de mettre à mettre ma musique
dans une case alors c'est passé par tous
les chemins folk pop ce qu'on a dit de
vous c'était ça ouais jazz AR enfin en
fait je pense que vous avez raison
personne arrive à trouver mais c'est
parce que je pense que je suis un
produit de euh de plein de choses je
suis d'origine comorienne je suis née en
France j'ai voyagé tout le temps depuis
que je suis jeune donc j'ai j'ai tout
glané à droite et à gauche et et en fait
je suis touché par le Hipop de la même
manière que je suis touché par le rock
ou la musique classique donc forcément
tout ça ça fait partie de ma
construction et donc forcément ça va se
ça va se retrouver dans mon dans ma
façon de créer ouais et ça rentre nulle
part quoi et du coup ça rentre nulle
part mais parce que mais même moi en
tant que personne j'avais jamais eu
l'impression de rentrer où que ce soit
j'ai toujours été trop grande pour mon
âge j'ai toujours une voix trop grave
pour mon sexe enfin voilà donc je j'ai
jamais eu l'impression d'être comme les
autres donc ça me choque pas donc je je
pourrais pas vous répondre je dirais pas
que musique du monde ça marche parce que
en même temps tout est musiques du monde
quelque part euh c'est un peu fourout
donc si ça vous va ça me va aussi voilà
votre nom de scène Imani signifie ma foi
en arabe c'est ça vous avez foi en quoi
en vous par exemple déjà c'est quelque
chose sur quoi je travaille encore
beaucoup mais je me dis quand même que
pour se dire je veux être chanteuse et
je vais payer mes factures avec la
musique il faut avoir un peu de foi
quand même la foi un peu de folie aussi
donc j'ai j'ai la foi en moi en tout cas
j'essaie de la maintenir quoi parfois
oui parfois non et je doute de moi etou
c'est pas toujours le cas vous avez pas
toujours c'est pas toujours non c'est
pas toujours le cas j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu la bataille d'une vie
entière h mais j'ai fois en plein plein
de choses j'ai foin franchement j'ai
quand même FO en l'humanité encore je
pense qu'il y a plus de bien que de mal
c'est juste qu'on se focalise beaucoup
sur le mal et j'ai foi en l'univers j'ai
foi en Dieu j'ai foi en j'ai foi en pas
mal de choses en réalité votre vrai nom
c'est Nadia mljao ah bien dit ah c'est
vrai je me suis pas entraîné avant vous
êtes né donc à martig près de Marseille
surnommé la 5è h des Comores et vous
l'avez dit votre famille est originaire
des Comores vous y alliez de temps en
temps en famille quand vous étiez
petitte en gros tout le 5 ans c'est ce
que je vous ai entendu dire vous avez
six frères et sœurs votre père était
militaire dans l'armée de l'air
française souvent en détachement à
l'étranger lorsqu'il est arrivé en
France il était plein d'espoir il disait
à tout le monde c'est le pays des droits
de l'homme est-ce que le pays a été à la
hauteur de ses attentes finalement euh
je pense oui et non parce qu'en fait à
la fin il a un peu déchanté de ça je
pense que il pensait que ça allait être
plus facile que ça pour ses enfants et
je pense que ça a été après ça s'est
vite transformé en Nadia tu es une femme
noir tu vas devoir travailler deux fois
plus que les autres pour avoir peut-être
la moitié de ce que eux ils ont donc
assez vite quelques années plus tard
quand je suis arrivé oui lycée fac par
là ça avait un peu changé je pense qu'il
a été déçu c'était un peu l'armé
d'ailleurs apparemment à la maison vous
racontez que parfois vous étiez réveillé
par des sudos sur la tête hein quand il
y avait un petit peu de retard quand ça
traînait un petit peu et aujourd'hui il
va à vos concerts et il est fier de vous
il a pas le choix quand même euh oui les
pseudos c'était pas régulier mais la
menace du pseudo marche aussi bien que
le pseudo hein donc il y a voilà et en
fait quand on a eu une seule fois le
sudo en vérité on a pas une deuxième
fois mais il l'a fait il l'a fait il l'a
fait et donc on il nous réveillait tôt
pour aller courir avant d'aller à
l'école enfin c'est c'était quand même
euh euh l'armée quoi l'armée ouaais je
suis même allée en école militaire mais
justement à 10 ans vous êtes mise à
l'internat de jeunes filles comme vos
grandes sœurs un internat pour enfants
de militaire et vous dites c'est plus
difficile pour vous parce que j'étais
une à maman donc pour vous c'était un
petit peu compliqué et là-bas vous
apprenez là aussi je vous cite he
comment être une bonne femme au foyer
comment bien passer la serpillère et
faire des bonnes tartes aux pommes
j'exagère pas c'est vraiment ça qu'on
vous a appris oui mais en fait c'est
c'est drôle mais c'est exactement çaoui
ça paraou faire le point de croix aussi
c'est important
euh en fait c'était une école qui
n'existe plus aujourd'hui mais qui avait
été créée après la Première Guerre
mondiale pour les pupill de l'air mais
que les fill donc elles avaient perdu
leurs parents à la guerre OK et il
fallait en faire des futures épouses h
donc le programme il avait juste pas
changé dans les années 90
donc on était quand même content du
cours de la tarte aux pommes il faut pas
croire que ou il faut pas diaboliser
c'était bah c'est pas ça c'est-à-dire
que bon entre faire une tarte aux pommes
et un cours de math demander à n'importe
quel enfant aujourd'hui peut-être qu'il
va choisir oui c'est vrai oui mais c'est
l'intention qui peut être gênante c'est
de faire de vous une bonne mère au foyer
c'est ça qui peut être un peu
déstabilisant quand on est est une jeune
fille bah en fait on vous le dit pas
comme ça et euh mais maintenant moi je
enfin peut-être que quand je suis sorti
de là j'étais devenue j'ai j'étais ultra
révolté et et quelques années plus tard
je me rends compte que quand même ce
qu'on m'a offert c'est de l'indépendance
c'estàdire que bah on dépend de plus
personne on a on on effectivement on
s'est lire écrire compter on a une
éducation qui est l'éducation nationale
hein c'est pas le programme il est
exactement le mêmeoui d'accord mais euh
mais je sais me faire à manger je sais
passer la serpillère je sais repriser
mes chaussettes et en fait c'est pas
rien
dépendre de personne sur des choses
aussi basiques que se nourrir euh et
effectivement je sais bien faire la
tarte au pom mais c'est pas mal aussi
quand on reçoit les gens chez soir
justement j'ai un document à vous
proposer je vais le lire hein pour les
les gens qui nous écoutent je vais le
déchiffrer un peu aussi pour vous parce
qu'il est pas simple à à lire il a été
délivré par nos partenaires les Archives
nationales il date de septembre 1931
c'est une lettre retrouvée dans le
dossier de carrière de professeur Simone
de Beauvoir au moment de sa prise de
fonction d'enseignante dans un lycée de
jeunes fillees tiens tiens et elle écrit
très simplement ces mots j'ai l'honneur
d'accuser réception de mon avis de
nomination évidemment je crois que vous
avez compris pourquoi je vous propose à
vous ce document mais on va le dire pour
les téléspectateurs pour les gens qui
nous écoute votre découverte de Simone
de beauauvoir à 14 ans va être un déclic
vous tombez sur les Mémoires d'une jeune
fille rangée et c'est grâce à elle que
vous prenez conscience de votre liberté
de femme c'est à ce point-là c'est comme
ça que ça s'est passé ouais exactement
ça s'est passé comme ça de ma condition
de femme pas vraiment de liberté de
femme d'accord parce que je comprends
que ma condition de femme elle est pas
si libre que ça et que en fait je ne
suis pas obligé ce qui était pas une
évidence avant d'arriver à l'âge de 14
ans je suis pas obligé de savoir
effectivement être maîtresse dans l'art
de passer la serpière ou faire la
vaisselle et que mon destin il est pas
d'être l'épouse de quelqu'un ou voilà
donc je comprends en lisant ce livre que
mon ma destinée elle est beaucoup plus
entre mes mains que je ne le crois et ça
change tout en fait vous vous souvenez
de de mots peut-être qui ont été dans
votre lecture de Simone debauvoir qui
ont pu être des
déterminant je sais pas si c'était pas
la phrase on ne n'est pas femme on le
devient ou quelque chose comme ça euh
qui qui qui ont l'air de rien mais en
fait bah à 14 ans ça vous explique plein
de choses parce qu'on croit bah non on
vous dit à chaque fois tu peux pas faire
ça tu es une fille tu peux pas faire ça
tu es une fille tu peux pas faire ça tu
es une fille et puis finalement
euh tu comprends que c'est une
construction social mental l'entourage
de l'entourage religieuse même parfois
voilà à la luur de celle que vous êtes
aujourd'hui quel conseil donneriez-vous
à la petite fille que vous étiez
qu'est-ce que vous lui diriez avant
qu'elle ne se lance dans la vie
justement bah ça dépend à quel âge quoi
quel âgé ah 6 ans 6 ans ouais qu'est-ce
que vous lui dites à la petite fille de
6 ans c'est toujours dur ces questions
c'est pour ça qu'on les pose euh à la
fille de 6 ans je dirais de pas grandir
trop vite d'essayer de pas grandir trop
vite en fait il y a il y a c'est pas si
intéressant que ça enfin c'est pas que
c'est pas intéressant le monde des
adultes mais que en fait l'enfance ça
vaut vraiment la peine d'être vécu moi
je pense que j'ai pas été une enfant
très longtemps et que je le réalise
maintenant étant adulte que il m'a
manqué beaucoup et je lui dirais de
prendre son temps en fait que il y a
rien de mal à réasser parce que ça il y
avait un truc onarrêtait pas de me dire
Nadia tu as la tête en l'air tu réasses
descends sur terre et en fait on a toute
la vie d'adulte à être vraiment sur
terre et même sous terre
parfois je lu dirais qu'il y a rien de
mal à être qui est elle est que il y a
rien de anormal à être qui elle est
parce que ça ouais j'aurais bien aimé
l'entendre votre premier acte de révolte
féministe c'est de vous couper les
cheveux vous aviez vos longs cheveux et
que je crois votre mère vous tressait
tous les dimanches et c'était un
calvaire pour vous et vous décidez de
les couper c'est c'est j'ai dit acte de
révolte féministe c'est un peu
ça à l'époque c'est pas comme ça que je
le vois mais peut-être qu'avec le recul
oui en fait j'en peux plus de tous les
dimanches perdre mon dimanche j'ai envie
de faire autre chose faire des tra c'est
vrai que j'ai des cheveux très longs et
crépus et c'est une galère pour ma mère
et en plus elle tire je pleure on se bat
et en fait sur une blague comme ça mon
père me dit bah si tu veux on racee tout
et je le regarde je fais ouais et en
fait je me suis senti très très libre
parce que je me suis dit c'est c'est ces
cheveux là ça me ça m' ça m'enchaîne à
la chaise tous les dimanches alors que
je pourrais faire des choses plus
intéressantes ils vous ont compris vos
parents votre mère non pas du tout ma
mère et mes sœurs d'ailleurs elles ont
pleuré elles ont cru que j'étais devenue
fol non des cheveux
ou mon père était tout content de toute
façon lui il voulait un garçon donc
c'était je m'en rapprochais du coup
ouais euh et de manière générale votre
féminisme vos sœurs et vos mères l'ont
compris ou pas ce féminisme l'ont envié
même peut-être cette liberté que vous
preniez tout d'un coup elles m'ont pas
dit siell l'ont envé je veux dire
jusqu'à ce jour elles se foutent encore
de moi
euh je pense que ma mère elle comprend
toujours pas elle comprend que je
voulais pas être enchaîné au d'accord à
la chaise du dimanche ouais mais que
c'était peut-être un peu radical de se
raser la tête voilà mais ça l'était
certainement ouais à 17 ans vous êtes
repéré dans le métro et vous devenez
manquin c'est une autre étape cruciale
de votre émancipation ça vous permet de
partir de chez vous de quitter le giron
familial où vous vous sentiez un peu à
l'étroit et vous arnaquez un peu votre
père pour avoir le droit de partir à New
York je crois vous profitez d'une
liaison téléphonique pas très bonne
puisque lui à ce moment-là il est en
détachement au Kosovo et vous lui dites
je pars à New York et il vous dit oui
oui mais en fait il sait pas très bien à
qui enfin à quoi il dit oui c'est ça
c'est même pire que ça c'est-à-dire que
à l'époque moi je suis athlète de haut
niveau j'étais je j'ai du son hauteur
donc je fais l'allerretour comme ça avec
Vincen linep et j'habitais dans le 78 et
déjà mon père il était pas hyper content
que je sorte un peu de ce que les autres
faisaient mes autres frères et sœurs du
coup ils étaient encore en internat et
moi ça grâce à à ça déjà je sors de
l'internat puisque ce coach euh qui me
repère et qui qui m'intègre dans
l'équipe h donc déjà il était pas très
content donc quand on me propose de
devenir mannequin j'appelle pour savoir
s'il était ok pour que je sois juste
mannequin moi j'aiis des copines qui
bossaient au McDo à l'époque donc je
préférais faire le manquin quand même
bien sûr du coup il a mal compris il a
dit oui oui ok et quand il arrive c'est
trop tard en fait c'est trop tard pour
dire donc il est rentré vous vous étiez
à New York mannequin il est rentré non
il voyais les castings déjà puis hop je
suis parti en fait New York c'est une
autre plus grosse arnaque mais je peux
le dire elle est au courant maintenant
ah d'accord c'est que New York j'y vais
pour un job
qui doit durer 3 semaines et finalement
j'adore tellement que je me dis il faut
absolument que je trouve un moyen de
rester là-bas donc j'étais à la fac à
l'époque en fac d'histoire et je dis je
vais faire une année sabatique je savais
que ça allait pas être une année
sabbatique mais je pouvais pas lui dire
j'arrête les études pour aller vivre à
New York ouais donc c'est là que j'ai un
et alors cette prise de connaissance
avec le milieu du manquina qu'est-ce que
ça je je crois que ça vous lasse assez
vite hein vous vous sentez vite un
porteementau en fait là aussi est-ce que
ça vient heurter un peu votre féminisme
et votre liberté qui qui
semble oui ma liberté oui parce Queen
fait franchement on utilise 10 % de son
cerveau même pas donc je m'ennuie donc
du coup ça me ça me déprime profondément
en fait et puis en plus tout c cette
espèce de quête de l'argent faire les
castings attendre comme ça des heures et
être jaugé sur le physique je trouve ça
violent mais c'est vraiment c'est
subtile en fait ça met du temps avant
que je comprenne que elles sont mal
menées un peu les mannequins c'est c'est
c'est c'est c'est un milieu difficile
quand on est une femme c'est un milieu
difficile c'est un milieu où on protège
pas vraiment les filles puisqueen plus
elles arrivent à un âge très jeune et
queil y a plusieurs catégories il y a le
mannequin qui va gagner des millions il
y a le mannequin qui va gagner moins
puis mannequins qui gagnent pratiquement
rien mais qui sont toujours dans une
attente de gagner un peu et il y a pas
beaucoup d'affect he pour les mannequins
elles ont pas vraiment besoin le droit
de se plaindre par qu'apprès tout elles
sont payé beaucoup d'argent juste pour
être belle et en même temps bah elles
doivent faire leur construction d'adulte
je veux dire vous avez 16 17 ans vous
êtes pas tout à fait une adulte et on va
vous dire tu es trop ceci tu es pas
assez cela et vous rentrez chez vous et
en fait vous construisez là-dessus en
plus de tous les problèmes avec lesquels
vous êtes venus votre goût et même votre
passion pour la musique vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure démarre aux États-Unis
hein et notamment lorsque vous entendez
Tracy Chapman revenons quand même sur
cette voix qui vous aait tellement
complexée avant et qui tout d'un coup
peut-être à l'écoute de Tracy Chapman
vous fait dire mais en fait je peux
utiliser cette voix que je trouve trop
euh masculine en fait ça va devenir mon
atout c'est à ce moment-là que ça ça se
joue pas exactement en fait moi j'ai
toujours justement la petite fille de 6
ans dont vous parlez j'ai toujours voulu
être chanteuse je le savais très tôt ah
d'accord toujours mais mon père on y
revient et il là à chaque fois et il
m'avait complètement découragé à
l'époque il m'avait dit mais non mais
chanteuse mais c'est même pas un métier
tu rigoles euh n'importe quoi on n'est
pas venu décomor ta mère et moi pour que
tu sois chanteuse enfin il y avait une
pression déjà là donc j'avais mis ça de
côté c'est seulement quand j'arrive aux
États-Unis que je me dis ah tiens
peut-être que ce rêve de chanteuse il
est possible ici et tr Chapin je suis
petite quand je la découvre et je me
rends compte que il y a des femmes qui
ont des voix atypiques et dites d'homme
en fait en plus à l'époque et euh qui
touch les gens puis je la vois Wembley
en fait donc elle est toute seule avec
sa guitare et il y a des milliers de
gens qui la trouvent incroyableouou donc
ça met quand même du temps ça met quand
même tout ce temps-là euh une dizaine
d'années ou pour moi de rassembler le
courage euh déjà rassembler le courage
de partir de chez moi accepter que je
peux devenir quelqu'un sans l'influence
de mes parents ou de mon cadre social et
donc vous vous libérez aux États-Unis
mais finalement c'est pas aux États-Unis
que vous choisissez de faire carrière
c'est plutôt en arrivant en France où on
trouve votre voix typique on a envie de
vous aider et de vous lancer finalement
vous avez été plus libre ici de vous
lancer dans votre passion la musique
plutôt qu'aux États-Unis aux États-Unis
c'est mon apprentissage en fait c'est
mon déclic aux États-Unis le fait que je
suis un mannequinord qui a besoin de
travailler mais qui du coup j'ai quand
même besoin de payer mes factures je me
trouve vraiment beaucoup à galérer donc
je suis la serveuse je suis au test je
distribue des flyers donc fait je
travaille jour et nuit ne serait-ce que
pour payer les factures et ça ça me rend
dingue et je me dis ça peut pas être ma
vie et à ce moment-là je cherche le rêve
et donc je me dis bon si je galère au
moins ce sera pour quelque chose qui en
vaut la peine et donc je commence à
prendre des cours de chant et donc je
commence à à à apprendre à écrire des
chansons parce que je connaissais rien
du tout de la musique qu'est-ce que
c'était qu'un couplet qu'un refrain donc
je je je deviens une autodidacte en fait
et je fais mes propres maquettes et je
rencontre des producteurs et ils veulent
tous me voir chez eux à 23h tous donc du
coup je décide de rentrer chez moi en me
disant que ça va pas que que mon temps à
New York il il est terminé puis ça
commençait à me peser les États-Unis
j'en avais un peu marre de ce pays de
coffee on the go voyez on peut pas
s'asseoir tranquillement avec les gens
enfin voilà la France commence à manquer
en fait ma famille aussi c'est voilà ça
faisait 8 ans quand même donc je suis
retourné à en en France et en France et
là on vous ouvre ouvre des portes et là
ouais et en fait mais mais et on vous
attend pas à 23h chez chez soi on m'a
non ah non et d'ailleurs j'ai beaucoup
plus de mal à rencontrer des gens du
métier Queaux États-Unis mine de rien
c'est beaucoup plus compliqué donc j'ai
dû faire toute seule avec ma sœur à
l'époque donc on essaie de créer des
opportunités créer des showcases entre
nous avec le peu d'argent que j'arrive à
mettre de côté enfin et ce je dors sur
son canapé à l'époque euh jusqu'à ce
qu'il y a un producteur qui me repère et
qui me surveille et au bout d'un moment
bah il me SIG votre premier single est
un carton you will never know autre
succès la bande originale du film
d'audre Dana sous les jupes des filles
un film de femmes pour les femmes et par
les femmes avez-vous dit à l'époque on
est en 2014 on ne parlait pas encore de
sororité ce mot très à la mode
aujourd'hui mais j'ai l'impression que
c'est un peu ça que que vous avez vécu
cette espèce de sororité ça vous parle
c'est quelque chose qui sur cet album
oui et de manière générale la sororité
vous l'avez ressenti vous l'avez vécu
sororité euh moi je le connaissais le
mot déjà depuis les États-Unis puisque
c'est un mot américain et puis je suis
d'une famille de de SEP enfants mais il
y a pratiquement que des
filles j'étais dans un internat de
filles ou le manquina c'est un lieu de
filles ou je connais que les filles je
connais que la sororité moi tout ce truc
de la compétition entre les femmes et ça
j'ai jamais connu ça d'accord j'ai
jamais vu ça j'ai toujours vu ça comme
de la compétition
entre enfin en plus moi je viens d'un
milieu de l'athlè
la compétition ça existe mais j'ai
toujours connu de manière saine pas dans
ce truc de la jalousie construite pour
moi qui est une invention du patriarcat
pour pouvoir nous on SCPE le chignon
pendant que eux ils font les caisses
voilà
mais je je ne connais que la sororité
j'ai j'ai pas j'ai pas attendu que ça
devienne un mot
ouais j'ai des photos à vous proposer ça
fait partie des rituels de cette
émission la première photo la voici il
s'agit d'Alexandre bonpard PDG du groupe
Carrefour pourquoi je vous en parle
parce qu'il a annoncé qu'il permettrait
à ses employés souffrant d'endométriose
de poser un arrêt maladie en cas de
règles douloureuse et c'est une première
pour une multinationale française et je
sais que c'est un sujet qui vous touche
de près c'est un de vos combats que l'on
parle de l'endométriose ça fait partie
des initiatives incroyables assez
récentes vous saluez j'imagine ah ben
bravo non franchement j'étais pas au
courant bravo parce que moi quand j'ai
commencé à parler de l'endométriose
c'était un peu plus de 10 ans et
franchement les médias ils en parlaient
pas pas du tout arrive même pas à dire
le mot en une seule trate
euh et que avec l'association
Omine depuis depuis 10 ans vraiment on
se bat pour que ce mot il existe pour
que cette maladie soit mieux prise en
charge l'association a travaillé de très
près avec ce gouvernement justement pour
que ce soit le la cause du
quinquena et donc si ça arrive jusqu'aux
oreilles de ces mecsl voilà de ces
patrons pardon euh bah c'est que on a
fait quelque chose parce que c'est quand
même des douleurs si on peut en parler
de de secondes c'est quand même des
douleurs qui qui sont tellement
invalidante qu'on peut pas du coup aller
au travail on peut pas avoir des
relations sexuelles normales on peut pas
avoir des relations amicales normales ça
c'est la première cause d'infertilité en
France enfin bon et après il y a tout un
tas de de choses qui rayonnent sur
différents types de cancer euh si les
hommes ils avaient mal une fois par mois
au point qu'ils peuvent pas sortir de
leur lit je pense qu'on aurait trouver
une solution no
comment une deuxième photo il s'agit de
Claris AG benénou qui est une très
grande championne de judo qui en plus de
ses exploits sportifs a fait parler
d'elle en amenant sa fille à ses
entraînements pour l'alléter elle a
voulu envoyer un message aux maman et au
papa leur montrant que c'était possible
d'allier carrière carrière sportive et
parentalité qu'en pensez-vous est-ce que
vous trouvez que c'est toujours
difficile de concilier les deux et
qu'elle a raison d'envoyer ce genre de
message alors c'est beaucoup de
questions alors je dirais que moi quand
j'ai accouché 3 mois plus tard aussi
j'étais sur la route avec le bébé ouais
donc je l'ai amené jusqu'à ces 11 mois
et j'ai allaité aussi par jusqu'à ces 12
mois donc parce que aussi je voulais
allaitter que c'était la condition aussi
pour que je reprenne la route c'était
que je puisse être là
pour pas pour mon enfant et en même
temps c'était mon travail h euh avec le
recul je sais pas si j'ai bien pu
profiter euh et de le début de cette
maternité et de
euh je sais pas ça c'est c'était très
compliqué et à la fois j'étais content
d'avoir le bébé avec moi je pense
qu'elle a elle a quelque part elle a
raison de dire la vie continue en fait
ouais et en même temps je pense que les
femmes qui ne se sentent pas de le faire
elles devrai aussi pouvoir ne pas se
sentir coupable ouais si elles peuvent
faire une pause en vérité je crois que à
refaire moi je le referai pas une
dernière question qui est en lien avec
ce lieu le lieu dans lequel nous sommes
nous sommes entourés de quatre statutes
chacune représentant une vertu il y a la
sagesse la prudence la justice et
l'éloquence est-ce qu'il y a une de ces
vertus qui vous parle en particulier ou
une autre qui n'est pas ici mais dont
vous auriez envie de dire de mots la
sagesse la justice l'éloquence les la
prudence et la prudence
h par réflexe je dirais la sagesse mais
on se serait vu il y a quelques années
j'aurais dit la
justice on s'arrêtera sur ces deux mots
un peu des deux merci im d'avoir été
notre invité dans un monde à regard
merci beaucoup à vous de nous avoir
suivi comme chaque semaine émission vous
pouvez évidemment retrouver en podcast
n'oubliez pas à très vite sur public
Sena
[Musique]
merci